[Applaudissements]
30 ans 30 ans que le mur est tombé
ce morceau du mur vient du mur
aujourd'hui encore on peut acheter des
morceaux du mur ou de murs quelques
euros il est pour vous le mien vient
peut-être d'ici c'est la bernauerstrasse
un morceau du mur tel qu'il est resté
après qu'il ai marre ou inspectent sont
passés un myspace
c'est un petit verre du mur ils ont
essayé de le détruire la bernauerstrasse
c'est aussi l'endroit où était pris
cette fameuse photo du soldat qui saute
par dessus le mur avant qu'il en soit 1
puisque au milieu de la nuit on a mis un
fils barbelés pour empêcher les gens de
son échappée la bernauer strasse est un
mémorial on trouve de tout ici
un morceau du mur tel qu'il était bien
ratissé un mirador un chemin de ronde et
des lampadaires
il y a aussi ce bosquet une expérience
étrange c'est pour voir combien de temps
la nature a besoin pour avaler le mur on
est écolo en allemagne à la bernauer
strasse
on trouve aussi c'est qu'elles sont
appelées fenêtre archéologiques
archéologiques témoignent d'un temps
entre 63 et 65
quand le mur a été remonté re démonter
modifié changé attendez 65 années de mon
essence je suis un dinosaure
je suis né en afrique faute à mein
l'allemagne de l'ouest
si je vous en parle ça a son importance
car il y à un franck fortin daoud de
l'autre côté
moi je suis ce qu'on appelle la vessie
ex v6 bien sûr mais de l'autre côté et
habiter l'est aussi quand j'étais petit
en parlez pas du mur c'était un mur une
frontière
ma maîtresse préféré de parler de
ensuite on venait de passer
le procès de francfort où nous a bien
expliqué les horreurs de
nos grands parents l'allemagne a été
divisé en quatre parties le nord pour
les anglais l'ouest pour les français et
le sud pour les américains berlin aussi
étaient divisés ainsi qu évidemment il y
avait la partie russe qui a été barbelés
mon premier contact avec un autre côté
c'est comme mon frère a ramené son
meilleur copain gunther gunt est un
hangar sont un peu étranges
il connaissait pas ses parents oui il
vivait avec depuis seulement six mois
ses parents étaient comme lui des aussi
mais politiquement incorrect instable
mis en prison torturés pendant trois ans
à peu près avant que mon allemagne
décide d'acheter leur liberté ainsi ont
été libérés à peu près trente mille
prisonniers politiques
ça coûtait entre 50000 et 100000 marque
ça à peu près la même chose en euros
aujourd'hui plus tard mes parents
avaient déjà décidé qu'on allait
s'expatrier au brésil il trouvait que
c'était une bonne idée d'y aller voir la
capitale
mais ma mère avait peur elle était née à
gdansk
et comme les gens de l'est devaient
rester à l'est on est resté devant le
mur et on a pris l'avion
on a même trouvé le prospectus il y
avait une promo
mais je suis désolé pas de photos du mur
j'ai bien été sur une de ces plateformes
pour regarder par dessus le mur mais bon
je ne suis pas kennedy
je n'ai pas dit je suis un berlinois et
puis à l'époque il y avait pas de celle
financ lui sans parler que c'est un mur
on a fait des photos j'ai même trouvé
mon journal ja première faits qui nous
en fait
c'est marqué que la quadriga vous voyez
a été exprès retourner pour montrer son
derrière à l'allemagne de l'ouest
mais c'est n'importe quoi puisque en
face du bras du beau gâteau nous avons
pardon nous avons servient nous avons le
boulevard unter den linden qui en fait
l'équivalent des champs-elysées il est
évident que la quadriga regarde en avant
en repartant nous avons fait une photo
de l'aéroport beaucoup plus joli
le mur
quelques années plus tard je suis revenu
en europe
pas loin d'ici ou tant que jeune fille
au pair et mes amis avaient décidé que
comme les abîmes allemande sous la main
on allait partir à berlin serge gibert
lance une dizaine de voitures farian
nous avons pris donc la voiture et
traversé l'allemagne de l'ouest son
problème et nous sommes arrivés à la
frontière vers l'allemagne de l'est
une demi heure à la douane un tampon
nous avons pris celui d'une heure et là
vous avez 200 km vont traverser
l'allemagne de l'est
100 km/heure facile à calculer 200 km
200 km heure ça nous fait deux heures
plus tard au prost frontière de montrer
à berlin ouest
mais annie de repayer cinq marques ou si
vous voulez de frais de passage
moi non c'est un monde et j'avais le
droit de traverser de l'allemagne vers
l'allemagne et on est à moi payer
quelques milliards juste pour entretenir
la route
arrivé de l'autre côté nous avons
vraiment de temps en était un peu
fatigué petit détail
si vous vouliez pas à si vite votre
voiture au moment d'arriver à la
frontière de bernard était démontée pour
voir si vous n'avez pas emmener
quelqu'un sur le chemin
par contre si vous rouliez trop vite
c'est évident et de cette vitesse
une annie l'a fait six heures au poste
elle était contente de partir avec une
de vos amours nous avons donc visiter
berlin
toujours pas de photos du mur mais j'ai
trouvé une carte postale qui j'ai acheté
à l'époque vous me reconnaissez sur la
photo donc je suis là le nom de ma nous
avons décidé d'y aller voir l'autre côté
à nouveau cette fois ci donc il fallait
passer la frontière berlin berlin allait
à l'est
nous nous approchons du checkpoint
charlie n'était coincé il y avait dû à
dubé du cdu des pour qui on voulait mes
amis et des français en voiture c'était
pratique celui là ap ir better nous
donnons nous passeport frôlant berck
raus les motos moi sortir de la voiture
mais pourquoi ici c'est le
poste-frontière faut les alliés vous
êtes allemande
vous allez au poste frontière de la
friedrichstrasse traîne ballast le
palais des larmes
pour ça il faut qu'on dise on de l'autre
côté je connais personne
raus mes amis ont suivi la frontière
puisqu'on n'avait ni gps des téléphones
portables et ont trouvé le poteau
prochain poste frontière moi je suis
passé l'a pas très accueillant cette
fois-ci moi aussi je devais payer les
cinq marques
c'était pas un droit de passage c'était
du tourisme pur et simple
et avec ça on devait payer 25 marques de
taux de change est obligatoire on marque
de l'est qui n'était pas veillé sur jab
quoi faire avec ça on pouvait louer un
appartement de 40 mètres carrés pendant
un mois on rester un mois on pouvait
acheter un soda pour 50 centimes 50
soldats pour une après midi nous avons
acheté une petite pub les progrès de la
ddr et nous sommes montés sur la tourte
et les magnifiques leur pack tout est à
peu près 20 marques ça tombait bien
on avait une vue panoramique pendant une
heure
idyllique et après mais après je suis
revenu en france
je me suis marié j'ai eu trois enfants
et quand le mur est tombé
qu'ils avaient même pas non les jumeaux
j'étais en train de faire les bagages
pour y aller chez mes parents pour leur
présenter quand même et je suis resté
devant la télé comme des milliers
d'autres personnes
j'ai eu des amis qui sont allés faire la
fête mais avec trois enfants c'est pas
possible
moi aussi j'ai eu peur quand les gens
sont montés
est ce que ces douaniers vont tirer
rien ne s'est passé le reste vous le
connaissez ils on parle en ce moment
partout mais revenons à la bernauer
strasse
ici il ya des gens qui sont morts dans
la plusieurs qui ont cherché la liberté
qu'ils ont payé avec leur vie j'étais
donc devant ses fenêtres archéologiques
quand je surpris la conversation de deux
touristes brésilienne c'est ici qu'ils
devaient avoir les fours crématoires non
je suis prof je parle portugais j'ai pas
pu m'empêcher ces touristes il s'extasie
même quand le mur n'est plus qu'un trait
dans l'as fait
je comprends ces berlinois
il n'aime pas le mur ils ont tout fait
pour le faire tomber le fractionné en
morceaux pour s'en débarrasser ils ont
dispersés à travers le monde entier
mais aujourd'hui il est protégé
il est même parfois rénové est
constamment ramener à la vie
tel un fantôme
il continue à nous hanter prenez garde
merci
[Applaudissements]